[Music]
dustin's going to start us off this hour
in kansas city hi dustin how are you
good how about you guys better than we
deserve what's up
hey yeah so i haven't done any drastic
decisions um but i know we all hate time
shares and i just kind of wanted to get
your opinion on disney's time sure
because i know that one's a little
different than the average time sure
it just sucks less
right
hey this is just two guys talking forget
that there's a couple million people
listening
what are you doing man why are you
calling this show
uh well you know i always go to dave for
advice i talked to him a couple months
ago and my father-in-law's been trying
to get me to get into dvc
um disney vacation club and you know
i always want to run my thoughts by dave
before i do anything oh you're awesome
yeah yeah okay i appreciate that
absolutely i like that very kind of you
um no i
disney is the best of the worst
but this is not a spectrum i even want
to live on yeah so um if you want to go
to disney it's wonderful just go down
there and rent your hotel and uh you
don't need to be putting your money into
timeshares timeshare is the is a
legalized fraud
uh and you know again the disney plan is
is it is the best plan of all of them
but they all suck this just sucks less
and i appreciate your father-in-law uh
he obviously thinks it's not but he's
wrong
um and my father-in-law has tried to
talk me into doing a couple things too
that i still love my father-in-law but i
didn't do those things yeah
when you say he's pressuring you what
does that what is that like put me a
picture of that i don't want i don't
want to say he's pressure i mean he's a
he's been in since 94. okay and you know
he's gone every year so it's paid out
for him and his opinion um he just you
know the last couple of years he's
always brought it up in conversation and
my wife and i have always brought it up
in conversation so
you know we're just sitting here sitting
around talking about it while we're in
disney last week
and you know thinking
yeah okay i actually thought you called
you're making a joke this is a you're
this is a heartfelt call and i i
apologize for making a joke i thought
you were playing with us um yeah
like i'm with dave i think all of our
father-in-laws want the best for us and
they have a picture of what the best is
and they and they encourage us either
loudly or subversively but yeah you got
to go with what's right yeah
my father-in-law's daughter that's
married to me yeah doesn't vote like him
oh yeah
and neither do i has he tried to
convince you of course yes but we we
gave up on that many years ago and we
just decided that we're going to be
friends anyway
even though he's wrong which isn't
insurance
it's just but i have for lots of friends
that are wrong so um that vote the wrong
way but um so
you know it's the same kind of thing
yeah i mean
here's the thing the bottom line of
disney or anything else when you're
buying a timeshare you're buying air you
do not have ownership you're basically
pre-paying for a hotel room for 30 years
do you have a 10 second what's the
difference between a disney one and
everyone else like why would somebody
say that
disney
is one of the only ones i think it may
be the only one that i've ever actually
witnessed you being able to sell it okay
there's enough of a market for them that
you can actually sell them guys you
can't give the other ones away yeah much
less sell them you can they're all over
ebay for a dollar you know wow and so
they're they're they you know they they
lose 100 of their value now disney does
not lose 100 of its value but
so you actually have an exit
you actually can sell the thing and exit
if you wanted to
on a disney one and that's
simply because it's disney and they've
just created such a strong market for
their
horrible time shares right you know but
they're just not as horrible as the
others and the numbers are better i mean
what you pay for what you get and it all
works out better but um especially given
that there's an actual ability that's
probably a market for you to sell it in
later but if you just run the numbers
out and just say okay
i i
very few people
like almost no one does what your
father-in-law has done which goes every
year
right
we go every year somewhere for a lot of
years but very seldom is at the same
place you know over and over it's one of
the problems with buying a vacation home
right is you trap yourself into that
same location again and again and again
and again you better love it you know
and
i just um i think he's wanting you to
live his dream yeah
and it made him happy and he wants that
for you but that doesn't mean it's a
wise purchase